[Music]
whoever walks away with this
million-dollar prize is gonna
quote-unquote make it when did you
realize that you made it
I want a modeling competition
competition show in Germany in 1992 and
then really I mean every step of the way
was kind of important for me but really
it started for me with Victoria's Secret
and being on the cover of Sports
Illustrated there wasn't social media
you know there wasn't with all this
internet says we have today so people
really went and bought the magazine and
it was in so many households overnight
and I think that's really what's in it I
remember like going to restaurant and
people be like rated I mean not that
they knew my name but they recognized me
from that cover right so I think that
really helped me a lot what's the piece
of advice that you wish someone told you
when you were first starting out in this
industry to always have fun I think at
the end of the day you know I mean I'm
always nervous to and I always was
nervous even at the beginning but you
have to have fun with what you do also
because if you don't have fun like why
you're trying so hard to be in that
industry you know you have to also do it
for the right reason there was a time
when people used to say supermodels can
only be supermodels you proved the
opposite of that you and Tyra Banks how
does that make you feel that that kind
of success I mean I don't know I didn't
even think that I was gonna even be a
model none of this you know all the
different things that I got to do
throughout my career you know I've been
in it since 1992 I get to do kind of
know the things that I over always
wanted to do like when I finished my
school I wanted to go to design school
in Dusseldorf and you know I got to do
all of that at the end pretty amazing to
be like really proud
you